(men imitate bell)
£ 'Cause you're a son
of a son of a son of a £
£ Son of a bitch bitch bitch £
(bell dings)
- [Rex] Keep your hands off my
woman!
- Your woman? I saw her first.
Don't put your hands on me!
- Don't put your hands on her.
That's my woman.
- And now for the scat stylings
of Rex The Bone Daddy Moss
and Teddy 12 Tones Louis.
(audience applauds)
(scat music)
(Rex and Teddy vocalize)
(Teddy vocalizes)
£ Your breath smells like a butt
£
(Teddy vocalizes)
£ Your whole mouth
smells like an open ass £
£ Butt poo-poo £
(Rex vocalizes)
£ You're fat £
£ You're a fat £
£ Fi fi fo fum £
£ What do I smell £
£ But some fat next to me £
£ That's the man £
(Rex vocalizes)
£ Fat £
(Teddy vocalizes)
£ Baby penis £
(Rex vocalizes)
£ Sucking it sucking it
sucking it sucking it £
£ Feel free to suck it £
£ You can suck it and then
put it in your mouth £
(Teddy vocalizes)
£ You're face your face £
£ Your face looks like a ball
sack £
£ A wrinkle dinkle do £
£ Stinky do ba de wrinkle
dinkle beanie ball sack £
(Rex vocalizes)
£ You a taint you're a
taint you're a taint £
£ The space between the butt and
balls £
£ Taint face you tainty
taint your face is a taint £
£ Taint taint taint £
£ Take it back £
£ No I won't £
£ I never will £
£ Take it back £
£ No I won't £
£ Never will no I wont £
£ Take it back £
£ Because you're a son of a son
of a £
£ Son of a son of a son of a
bitch £
£ Bitch bitch son of a son of a
son of a £
£ Son of a son of a bitch £
£ Bitch bitch bitch £
(audience applauds)
£ You don't need to fight over
me £
£ There's plenty of that £
(Woman scats)
£ Vagina £
£ There's plenty of £
£ You know what I'm talking
about right £
£ Y'all know what I'm talking
about £
(audience applauds)
(scat music continues)
(jazz music)
(trumpet blares)
(audience applauds)
(dish crashes)
(music continues)
(audience applauds)
(trumpets blare)
(audience gasps)
(audience applauds)
(audience cheers)
(music continues)
(trumpet blurts)
(audience applauds)
(trumpet blares)
(trumpets blare)
(audience applauds)
(men vocalize)
(audience applauds weakly)
- [Announcer] And now,
ladies and gentlemen,
the man you've been waiting for,
Mr. Micheal Winslow.
- Go get 'em, Winslow!
Bring the noise, bring the
noise.
Another sold out night for
the Kings of Mouthnoise.
But, I tell you though, we
wouldn't
have this audience without
Winslow.
Lucky for you, huh?
(Micheal vocalizes)
Those "Police Academy" fans.
Look at all the t-shirts.
Six sequels!
Can you believe it?
Every sound effect this
guy makes is like a little,
tiny Mona Lisa popping out of
his mouth.
Have you ever heard him do
the walking through the
leaves in the fall while he-
(dramatic music)
(distant applause)
(Bobby seethes)
(Micheal imitates wiping
vocally)
(Micheal chugs)
(Micheal gulps)
(Bobby vocalizes)
(Micheal squeaks)
(Bobby hums mechanically)
(Micheal whips vocally)
(Bobby whirs)
(Bobby vocalizes)
(Bobby and Micheal
vocalize fighting motions)
(Micheal warbles)
(Bobby vocalizes)
(Bobby whooshes)
(Micheal clicks)
(Micheal booms)
(Bobby whimpers)
(both pant)
(heart beats)
(Micheal beeps)
(Bobby vocalizes)
(Micheal's beeping plateaus)
(Micheal imitates alarm)
(upbeat music)
£ I want you £
£ But I don't need you £